Now, you might find this interesting.
I was wondering, how is right wing media going
to spin the violent, riotous insurrection
that took place in Washington, D.C. yesterday?
Will they say it was actually antifa and Black
Lives Matter?
The answer is yes.
Some of them did.
And I'll have clips of that for you a little
bit later.
How are they going to frame what is a rift
to some degree between Trump and much of the
rest of the Republican Party?
For example, I put the tweet up on the screen
for you earlier, which has since been removed
by Twitter of Donald Trump denouncing his
own vice president, Mike Pence, where he said
Mike Pence failed us and and I am not aware
and was not able to find in the historical
record for the last hundred and fifty years
a president denouncing his own vice president
in this way, I just wasn't able to find it.
How would right wing media deal with that?
I have one example for you, and it is it's
almost poetically just that it comes from
Fox and Friends host Ainsley Arehart, who
has been one of the most sycophantic and vile
brown nosers of this president for four years.
I hope you're sitting down for this.
Ainsley Earhart's framing was I hope Donald
Trump can forgive Mike Pence for not trying
to overthrow the election results.
Think about that, OK?
Donald Trump demanded that Mike Pence do the
impossible and the illegal and the immoral,
which is somehow stop Joe Biden from being
president, despite that being the will of
the people and then denounced his own vice
president after this violent insurrection
started.
Ainsley's idea is I really hope Trump will
forgive Pence.
Take a look at this video clip or you know
what?
Mike Pence can just wave that magic wand.
It'll all be fixed.
I hope that doesn't taint their relationship
because they have been such supporters of
one another and been a good team because Donald
Trump, how can it be good after that?
I'm sure it won't be.
But I hope that, you know, I hope the president
will be able to forgive him because Mike Pence
is such a stellar individual, has a walk with
God is amazing.
I mean, he's he's a good man.
And, you know, both of them have done a lot
to help the country.
And I hope that they can move forward and
move past this and just agree that there were
there were differences.
I'm sure the president feels like I'm responsible
for him becoming vice president.
So he should have done this for me.
But the president, as you've been saying all
along, Brian, the vice president has stood
by his side and supported him all along the
way.
So hopefully their friendship won't end after
this for the good of the country.
I betcha it's done.
Yeah.
So this is weaponized delusion and we're going
to have I couldn't possibly get all of these
clips for you now that this is this is one
type of reaction, which is a complete reframing.
It's like the equivalent of a lot of it's
a trapeze artist flipping around and turning
everything upside down and swinging wildly
from one place to another.
Some other networks and some other channels
and outlets were sort of pretending none of
this was going on.
Even Fox News at one point yesterday, five
hours into the riotous Ansara insurrection,
if you went to the Fox News website, all that
all it said was protesters delay counting
of electoral votes, which, if you had been
paying attention, does not exactly capture
the violence and and seditious nature of what
was going on yesterday.
Others, for example, Newsmax and on for much
of the day, we're just talking about completely
different things altogether.
It was like nothing is going on.
At one point last night, in fact, when the
electoral vote count continued, most cable
networks were covering it.
But if you turn to Fox News, it was Laura
Ingraham ranting about how maybe it was actually
antifa who did this in Washington, D.C. and
I'll get to those clips a little bit later.
So, as I said on yesterday's show, different
people deal with loss in different ways.
But what is abundantly clear is that there
is nothing too crazy.
There is nothing that these Trump supporters
can do that won't find some defense in some
right wing media.
And there is no absurdity to absurd that someone
on Fox News won't be able to come up with
some kind of pretzel logic pretzel.
I hope Trump forgives Pence.
Pence is disgusting, but at least Pence immediately
denounced the violence.
Full stop, reportedly as the guy who actually
called the National Guard to get to D.C.,
even though Donald Trump was resisting doing
it and immediately came back and said, let's
continue.
We're not going to be delayed from doing this
pences.
Horrible.
His failures on coronaviruses, religious nuttery,
I mean, he's he's horrible.
But the idea that Trump needs to forgive Pence,
if this is any indication of what Fox News
is going to look like for the next two or
four years, we are really in for it.
And after the break, we will get to, yes,
the idea that what could it have been antifa
that actually did the pro Trump insurrectionist
mob yesterday?
We'll get to that a little bit later.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.